Director Paul Thomas Anderson's 1997
classic Boogie Nights takes the audience
on a vivid ride through the golden years of
the porn industry. The story behind the film,
however, is almost as wild. This is
the untold truth of Boogie Nights.
Paul Thomas Anderson's father, Ernie "Ghoulardi"
Anderson, began his career in the 1960s as a
Cleveland television horror movie host. However,
he eventually found success as a Hollywood voice
artist, counting comedians, actors and
other Hollywood types among his friends.
Ernie had worked with Tim Conway at WJW-TV in
Cleveland in the '60s. Conway left to star in
McHale's Navy, but eventually Ernie joined
him in Los Angeles, and the rest is history.
According to Esquire, Ernie eventually bought
a big house in the San Fernando Valley,
where he would frequently play
host to his various funny friends,
like Conway and actor Harvey Korman — both
of whom had a "flair for twisted humor."
For Paul's 12th birthday, Ernie bought him a
Betamax camcorder. With the camcorder in hand,
Paul went on to make vignettes that followed his
father and his zany Hollywood friends. According
to Esquire, Paul's father likely inspired
Burt Reynolds' Jack Horner in Boogie Nights.
There were other inspirations as well. As
Paul explained to the Philadelphia City Paper,
"[Growing up in the San Fernando Valley], porn was
always around. There were these industrial-looking
buildings, with no signage, but you'd see people
going in and out; you knew what they were doing."
Anderson has been described by many of the
people involved in Boogie Nights as looking
like a kid when they first met him, which makes
sense since he was 26 at the time that he was
looking to helm his first big Hollywood feature.
However, Anderson had already made one movie about
Dirk and the porn industry when he was still in
high school. That film, The Dirk Diggler Story,
was a visual first draft for what he
would finally realize in Boogie Nights.
According to Grantland.com's
oral history of the movie,
Paul Thomas Anderson claims to have had an
epiphany about the name "Dirk Diggler" at 17.
He then wrote the name on a piece of paper, and
began putting together a student film using a
camcorder and a Steadicam. Anderson pulled
together his friends to play Dirk, Reed,
and various others in the low-budget film. He did
have one star involved, though: his dad, Ernie.
Back in the '90s, John Lesher was
a powerful talent agent. One of
his clients was Harmony Korine, a
talented young writer whose career
began when he wrote Kids at age 19. As
Deadline explained in a 2013 article,
Lesher championed Korine for years while
an agent at UTA and Endeavor, and Lesher
continued that support as a producer. Yet Lesher
had another wunderkind client at the time:
Paul Thomas Anderson. Michael de Luca, an exec
at New Line Cinema at the time, told Grantland,
"I was talking with John [Lesher] about the
movie 'Kids.' I passed when he brought it
to New Line [...] Just as a joke, I said to him,
'Don't let me pass on something this cool again,'
and later [...] John said, 'Remember when you
said don't let you pass on something cool?'"
Lesher then described in the article
how he met de Luca for drinks,
gave him the script for Boogie Nights,
and the next day they were in business.
According to entertainment journalist Sharon
Waxman, another reason for de Luca to pick up
Boogie Nights may have been that he was a, quote,
"bad boy" at the time. Waxman told Grantland,
"[Michael de Luca] loved that
life and he lived that life."
Whether it was good agenting or simply a case of
party boy meets party script, it seems as
destined as Dirk Diggler for greatness.
At 23, Anderson got into the Sundance
Film Festival with his short film
Cigarettes and Coffee. The following year,
Anderson came back to the Sundance Lab and
expanded on Cigarettes and Coffee
with his first feature, Hard Eight.
Paul Thomas Anderson titled it Sydney when
he first conceived the idea in high school.
The idea for the film came after he
watched a short Philip Baker Hall scene
as a consigliere named Sydney in Midnight Run.
Sydney was Anderson's working title for the film,
and he was infuriated when his backers took
final cut and the name away from him. The movie
had a budget of $3 million and starred Hall and
John C. Reilly as the leads, Gwyneth Paltrow and
Samuel Jackson as top supporting actors, plus
Philip Seymour Hoffman early in his career.
For a debut film from a 25-year-old kid, Hard
Eight notched great reviews and paved the way
for Anderson's first studio feature. The
budget for Boogie Nights was $15 million
and there were more actors and sets, but
Hall, Reilly and Hoffman all returned to
work with Anderson on a movie that would
help propel the careers of all four.
Despite the fact that the movie was an at
times depressing story about the porn industry,
a lot of actors were circling the script.
According to Grantland's oral history,
Drew Barrymore was Roller Girl at one point.
The role of director/producer Jack Horner,
however, was offered to a lot of big
talent. Bill Murray, Harvey Keitel,
Sydney Pollack and Albert Brooks were supposedly
all offered the role. But Paul Thomas Anderson
discussed it extensively with Warren Beatty.
"I got to know Warren many years
ago, about 20 years ago when I was
going to do 'Boogie Nights.' I sent him
the script and asked him to be in it."
As Anderson said in an interview with Charlie
Rose, Warren had shown a lot of interest in
playing the part of Jack Horner. However,
Anderson ultimately made a realization that
Beatty didn't necessarily want to play
the director. Anderson told Grantland,
"I started to figure out that Warren really wanted
to play Dirk Diggler (Mark Wahlberg). 'You don't
really want to play Jack Horner. You want to
be the kid in this movie.' He said, 'Yeah.'"
Horner eventually went to Burt Reynolds, and
it's hard now imagining anybody else playing
it. Though it appears that Reynolds brought
quite a few challenges to the production.
In an interview with GQ, Burt Reynolds was asked
if he'd work with Anderson again. His answer?
"I don't think so.
Personality-wise, we didn't fit."
According to the Grantland oral history,
there was even a moment when Anderson
gave Reynolds perhaps less respect than he
deserved, and it supposedly came to blows.
Burt Reynolds clarified to Conan O'Brien that
he hadn't punched Anderson, but wanted to.
"No, I didn't want to hit him in the
face — I just wanted to hit him."
According to The Hollywood Reporter's obituary
for the actor, Reynolds was so unhappy with the
film and his place in it that he fired his agent
after seeing it for the first time. It was ironic,
then, that he won his only film Golden
Globe for his turn as Jack Horner.
Plus he was nominated for the
best supporting actor Oscar,
although he eventually lost to Robin
Williams for his turn in Good Will Hunting.
One of the most intense scenes in "Boogie
Nights" occurs toward the end when Dirk,
Reed, played by John C. Reilly, and Todd Parker,
played by Thomas Jane, are sitting in the living
room of a crazy rich man's house, looking to
rip him off by selling him some fake dope.
In the scene, there's a random boy just walking
around throwing firecrackers at the floor.
Many of the cast recalled how that was
the craziest scene in the whole film,
and in large part that was due to the
unexpected randomness of the constant
mini-explosions. Director Robert Downey
Sr. said in Grantland's oral history,
"That idea came from a scene in my movie 'Putney
Swope.' It's one of Paul's favorites. My thing
was the Asian guy who's throwing around
firecrackers and just doesn't say a word."
Another inspiration, though, was Anderson's
father. According to Esquire, Ernie Anderson liked
"tossing firecrackers around." So there you
have it: Two showbiz fathers with a fondness
for firecrackers inspired one of the most insane
scenes in a movie full of intense sequences.
A few characters, or at least character names,
made it to Boogie Nights from The Dirk
Diggler Story. One of those is Reed Rothchild,
Dirk's best friend in the porn industry. In
the original, though, Reed was very different.
Reed was played by Eddie Dalcour, a bodybuilder
who was also Dirk's lover in that original
iteration. Dalcour features prominently in the
student film since he was Dirk's best friend.
There's even a scene where they're both
together in a hot tub. While the romantic
element of the Dirk/Reed relationship
didn't make it into Boogie Nights,
one Dalcour item did — Reed's hot tub poem.
According to the oral history, Dalcour was
constantly trying to get Anderson to crack
up on the set and was even invited to be
in Boogie Nights. However, by that point
Dalcour had begun his career as a Christian
minister, which would've been tough to square
with a film about drugs and porn. One of his
improvisations was the poem that John C. Reilly
recites as Reed while in the hot tub with Dirk.
It's a poem about love and honey trees and bees,
one so bad yet so amazing because of how well
it sets up the duo's rock solid friendship.
"I love you. You love me.
Going down the sugar tree."
"Did you write that?"
"Yeah. I write songs, too."
Anderson had been making movies since he
was 12, and some of those early ones were
actually scripted films. In fact
Anderson's early films all seemed
to march toward what he would eventually
realize in Hard Eight and Boogie Nights.
Obviously The Dirk Diggler
Story is a major stepping stone,
from the tale of Dirk's rise and fall to the fact
that recording "The Touch" was featured in both
as an example of Dirk's failed second career.
But according to Esquire, it becomes striking
how much of these films began when Anderson was
still too young to actually buy pornography.
Esquire mentions how Anderson first told a
teacher he was going to make a movie called
Sydney based solely on the snippet of
Philip Baker Hall he'd seen in Midnight Run.
As a young teen, however, he made a
Miami Vice parody called Brock Landers,
which went on to be the name of Dirk's
monumental X-rated action series.
"Does this character have a name?"
"His name is Brock Landers."
Anderson also made a Young Guns parody
called Young Buns, with erotic undertones.
If nothing else, Anderson was a
student of film from a very early age,
and didn't just want to watch them
but wanted to be part of them as well.
John Holmes was a very successful adult film
actor known for having a heavy drug addiction
and, eventually, his possible role in the
Wonderland Murders. According to Esquire,
Paul Thomas Anderson told a friend in high
school that the idea for his next movie
was inspired by the sad life of Holmes. In a
1997 interview with Philadelphia City Paper,
Anderson explained how Dirk's career
was very similar to that of Holmes:
"With the '80s and the drugs, everything's
taken a toll on him. That happened in John
Holmes' life and it was reflected in
the character he played [Johnny Wadd].
We did the same thing with Dirk, and in the
movie I blame the drugs and ego-building."
In that same interview, he also specifically
mentions the early Johnny Wadd films as
examples of great storytelling in porn.
There was also a John Holmes documentary
called Exhausted that was one of the
inspirations for Anderson to shoot The
Dirk Diggler Story as a mockumentary.
It was such a big inspiration that the
documentary was even an added feature on
a Criterion laserdisc of Boogie Nights,
with Anderson pointing out in the commentary
how the film was a, quote, "major influence."
A final shocking fact to come out of Boogie
Nights is that its star, a man still known
at the time as an underwear model and teen
idol called Marky Mark, has said that he
probably wouldn't do Boogie Nights again despite
having just a few acting credits at the time.
Yes, Mark Wahlberg said in a 2017 appearance that
he hopes God forgives him for his poor acting
choices, and that Boogie Nights is at the top
of the list. There was a lot of outcry about him
negating the movie that gave him serious acting
cred. As Julianne Moore put it to Andy Cohen,
"Oh my God, I think he should thank God
for 'Boogie Nights.' It made his career!"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.